hey this is pressed all Walker can you
figure out a pattern in these numbers
this intelligence test has been shared
on Facebook more than three million
times it's also gotten popular on
Twitter with the tagline that if you
understand it you have a genius IQ of
more than 150 points there are many
reasons to question these claims and
perhaps the most startling part about
this intelligence test is that you never
have to prove you understand the role
you can simply pretend you solved it by
sharing the post or sharing the tweet I
often get people who watch my puzzle
videos and tell me that it was so easy
they figured it out when I ask them what
the answer is they often tell me a
result which is the trap answer I think
in order to have an intelligence test
you should always prove that you
understand what's going on in a new
situation so I want to pose this problem
to you if you understand the rule you
should be able to solve this problem
give it a try and when you're ready keep
watching the video I'm going to explain
the rule of the intelligence test and
then solve this problem so when we're
looking for pattern these numbers we
might just start by adding up the
numbers and seeing if these numbers show
up anywhere in fact it turns out that
the sum of the two digits will be the
last two digits or the last digit and
our result now we need to figure out
where the first number or the first two
numbers of our answer come from while we
can do the other operation we can just
subtract the numbers and we'll quickly
see this is where the first number or
the first two numbers come from so we
figured out the intelligence rule we
want to add combined two numbers X and y
we'll take the difference of the two
numbers and then append it to the sum of
the two numbers so now let's test our
knowledge and see if we can solve a new
problem one way we can interpret this
problem is that we want two numbers to
combine so that the two numbers have a
difference of 1 and a sum of 23
we have a system of two equations and
X&Y if we add up these two equations we
can eliminate the Y variable so we have
2x equals 24 which we then solve that X
is equal to 12 y will be one less than
that so y equals 11 so we figured out 12
and 11 combined to be 123 but if we were
to truly have an intelligence house we
need to look for all solutions there's
another way we can interpret our problem
we could have two numbers combined so
that they have a difference of 12 and a
sum of 3 we can solve these equations
similarly and we'll get that X is equal
to 7 and 1/2 and Y is equal to negative
4 and 1/2 so this is another answer to
this new problem I've suggested I would
say this is a little bit more of an
intelligence test than the original
problem and now I'm going to ask you
share this video if you solve this new
problem be honest
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel I make videos on
math and game theory you can catch on my
blog mind your decisions which you can
follow on Facebook Google+ and patreon
you can catch me on social media at pres
collector and if you like the video
please check out my books there are
links in the video description